[Applause]
is the man who's always on vacation too
old to lead the nation a new poll finds
that an overwhelming majority of
Americans 77% think President Biden is
too old for a second term even 69% of
Democrats say Joe's no longer up to the
task and that's saying something because
half of those demn voters are
dead
Jimmy Jimmy
come on as for Joe if this month was any
indication he's already in full-on
retirement mode anything to add Mr
President no no no look
look I'm not old I'm not too old I I'm
like a kid but you know maybe I'm old
here and and here but not up here up
here I remember I can remember my phone
number as a kid uh it was uh let's see
was
it
hello hello is corn pob there yeah you
tell him it's pain and
suffering good
job Jamie Jamie Jamie we are begging on
Biden but wasn't he technically correct
at the State of the Union when he said
now is the time to choose between unity
and schme Ham
yes I thought I thought he made a great
point I don't think his like pal
prompter I don't think there's a lot of
spaces in it it's always just kind of
like one long s remember when he was
like build back better build back I was
like did he say bread milk butter are we
making
pancakes what is going they said did you
see well you just kind of said it but
like yeah 70% 77% said that he could not
didn't think he could continue
effectively and this is crazy but the
other 23% did you see this were
wrong and then um that's
crazy and then kind of a fun video where
he got he was getting booed wasn't that
kind of fun yeah yeah did you hear when
people were like Boo Boo he was like oh
my God the ghosts they're coming for
me Tyrus let's talk optics for a second
okay looking out at how bad the world is
what do you think's a better look for
America Trump in a mug shot or Biden in
a lounge chair
Trump in a mug
shot or Biden in allow yeah what do you
think they actually respect more like
seriously well I think they respect
whoever got Biden out of the lounge
chair because that was going to be quite
a task I think you want other countries
to see that our our president is willing
to go there yeah you know and his slogan
is the boys in the hood are always hard
talking trash will'll blow your car
knowing nothing life to be legit don't
with Trump I saying like that to me
Putin sees a mug shot he'll back up yeah
yeah they see old
grandpa kind of he doesn't claim them
all yeah sitting in a
chair going to be like you know what
maybe it's a good time now to invade
let's go let's go he's asleep cuz
chances are when they do come he's going
to be like oh look kids balloons like no
those are missiles Mr
President
I think what he said a spot on cat but
is the joke on us because Biden has been
telling people behind closed doors he's
going to beat Harry
[Music]
Truman I expect Truman to win the debate
but I I think Biden has a real shot here
Biden's he is old um he's not too old to
be fine after he got Co though which
makes it a lot harder for him to make me
afraid of Co yeah like if he could get
Co and live we could get anything right
I great I'm I'm going to be okay I don't
really think it's an age I've said this
before but the age thing yes there there
is there is a thing there but I don't
think his age even makes the list of the
things that I'm concerned about you know
like Paul McCartney is older than Joe
Biden I went and saw Paul McCartney live
last summer he put on a three-hour show
playing all these instruments singing
Joe Biden couldn't even make his way
onto that stage probably you know the
list of cons like he doesn't seem to
know who's a liive who's dead and thinks
dead people are in the room with him all
the time he shakes hands with the air
you know he babbles all I was raised by
Puerto Ricans like he said he had oil
cancer and all of us were just like
that's Joe like
what this is not normal like this is
supposed to be like get Joe Biden and
will it all be normal this nothing about
this is normal and I think it's an
insult to all of the wonderful brilliant
80s somethings in our audience to say
that it's an age thing it's it's if he
could do it's like he's proven to me
that age is just a number but not in the
way that he thinks he
[Laughter]
did be fair Jimmy uhhuh to be fair he
was never sharp in his 30s or 40s either
he was never let's be fair going to put
that out there yeah when they say he's
never front of the class like he lost
his fast ball I'm like hello he was
throwing 52 miles an hour thank you
that's a great Point uh Morgan someone
who worked in the state department
though let's talk about optics for a
second okay in what world does this
Administration think it's a good idea to
be showing the rest of the world our
president SE Cup breasts for the entire
month of
August yeah some of us get
jealous the female leaders are upset uh
you know I mean he probably needed the
vacation but it was it was a little
toned deaf When people's children are
literally Burning Alive in Hawaii and in
the United States and he just says no
comment as he gets off the beach I mean
the juxtaposition of of literally
someone I read these stories somebody is
stuck at work their kids are in their
house in Maui and their kids burned
alive while he's hanging out on the
beach and just says no comment don't
have anything to say about it today so
uh you know I don't know maybe he needs
the vacation I'll tell you I think I
said this earlier today I think term
limits would serve uh him would serve us
all really well I've been calling on
this for a long time you know he's been
in offenses I think he got elected when
he was 29 30 if we had term limits this
might not be an issue today and it goes
for both sides like get them out go find
something else to do with your time
like like you know it's bad when they
call the Oval Office Joe answers and
they're like can we speak to someone
quicker like fedman you
know dude that you laugh that fetman
video breaks my heart because if you
ever see the video where he's struggling
to pronounce I95 where he's like I95 and
he finally says it Biden yells out
[Laughter]
Bingo hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else